Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Io nasco nel 1980,
quindi per iniziare la mia storia
partirei da qui.
Il Novecento viene conosciuto,
e viene spesso definito,
"The century of self", il secolo dell'io.
Viene definito in questo modo
perché è il secolo dell'affermazione,
soprattutto in campo economico,
delle teorie di mercato e noeoliberiste.
Come diceva John Maynard Keynes,
spesso la motivazione del danaro
ci ha spinto, nel corso del tempo,
ad associare a chi utilizza il danaro
degli aggettivi che,
se li vedessimo associati
a delle persone che ci stanno vicino,
ci creerebbero non pochi fastidi.
Quando pensiamo al danaro,
pensiamo all'individualismo e all'egoismo,
alla competizione, all'avidità,
al profitto, al cinismo,
al potere, al materialismo.
Ma effettivamente,
queste qualità sono indispensabili
per quanto concerne quella visione
che è la visione economicistica del mondo
in cui questo homo economicus,
che è un uomo perfettamente razionale,
si muove per massimizzare
il proprio profitto.
Da dove deriva questa convinzione?
Deriva dal pensiero -
almeno così ci raccontano, molto spesso -
di questo economista
che si chiama Adam Smith.
Nella "Ricchezza delle nazioni",
questo è uno dei passaggi
che viene più spesso
strumentalizzato a questo proposito.
Cosa ci diceva Smith?
"Non è dalla generosità del macellaio,
del birraio o del fornaio
che noi possiamo sperare
di ottenere il nostro pranzo,
ma dalla valutazione che essi fanno
dei propri interessi".
Questo uomo qui, però,
oltre a scrivere
"La ricchezza delle nazioni",
scrive un altro libro che si intitola
"Teoria dei sentimenti morali".
E cosa dice?
Qual è l'interesse di ogni uomo?
"L'interesse di ogni uomo è la simpatia.
"Simpatèin" significa, per l'appunto,
vivere insieme agli altri
le emozioni degli altri.
Quindi significa condividere.
In un certo qual modo, significa empatia,
riconoscersi nell'altro.
Quindi, come vedete,
spesso alcuni dei dogmi, delle convinzioni
che accompagnano l'economia di mercato,
l'economia neoliberista,
non sono altro che dei fraintendimenti,
delle strumentalizzazioni.
Lo stesso concetto di efficienza:
pensate, tutti quanti,
in nome dell'efficienza,
siamo disposti a sopportare
qualsiasi tipo di fatica.
Questa è una definizione di economia
che trovate su Internet,
sui libri, sui testi di scuola:
l'economia è "la scienza che studia
l'allocazione di risorse limitate
tra usi alternativi,
al fine di massimizzare la soddisfazione,
ovvero il profitto dell'individuo,
il cui agire individualistico-razionale
ci dicono porti
alla migliore soddisfazione
dei bisogni collettivi".
Quello che dobbiamo chiederci è:
in che modo questo processo avviene?
A questo punto dobbiamo, anche,
chiederci se è vero
che gli unici bisogni che vengono presi
in considerazione dell'economia
sono i bisogni coperti da beni finanziari.
In che modo il consumatore,
che è il sovrano
di un'economia di mercato,
che decreta il successo o meno
di un prodotto,
di un'attività imprenditoriale,
vota?
La mercatocrazia, ahinoi,
non è una democrazia.
Mentre, in una democrazia,
per ogni testa c'è un voto,
nella mercatocrazia
per ogni unità di moneta -
per ogni dollaro,
per ogni euro - c'è un voto.
Come ben sapete,
questi voti non sono distribuiti
equamente nella popolazione.
Ma a questo punto, noi ci siamo chiesti:
se questo voto avviene
attraverso la moneta,
dovremmo magari cercare di capire,
assieme, che cos'è la moneta.
Prima abbiamo visto
che spesso ci rapportiamo alle cose
come se fossero, direbbe Searl,
questo filosofo, dei "fatti bruti",
ovvero delle cose che esistono oltre noi.
Ma se noi ci rapportiamo al danaro
come a qualcosa che esiste
al di là di noi,
come se fosse il vento, o una montagna,
allora non siamo in grado di capire
che il danaro è un costrutto antropico,
e che possiamo cambiare il modo
attraverso cui viene distribuito,
quindi cambiare le regole del credito,
e cambiare le regole stesse
attraverso cui la moneta
viene creata e distribuita,
e attraverso cui si muove.
Quindi, se io chiedessi in questa sala -
l'ho fatto centinaia di volte -
che cos'è la moneta,
otterrai centinaia di risposte
diverse l'una dall'altra.
Neanche la scienza economica
ha dato una risposta univoca
a questa domanda.
Il rapporto che noi abbiamo con il danaro
è lo stesso rapporto che,
Sant'Agostino diceva, l'uomo ha col tempo:
"Se nessuno me lo chiede",
diceva ne "Le Confessioni" Sant'Agostino,
"so cos'è. Se, interrogato,
devo rispondere, non so cos'è".
E allora noi siamo proprio partiti da lì.
E siccome nel 1971, non in tanti lo sanno,
ma vengono sospesi
gli accordi di Bretton Woods,
quindi dietro il danaro non c'è più
neanche la promessa di convertibilità,
che era propria del dollaro, in oro,
ma c'è semplicemente un accordo.
Fa parte della costruzione
della realtà sociale:
diciamo che fa parte
di una sorta di coscienza del noi,
quindi di un accordo.
Pertanto noi ci siamo ritrovati
nella definizione
per cui il danaro è un accordo,
all'interno di una comunità,
che decide di utilizzare un dato mezzo,
un dato strumento, come mezzo di scambio.
A questo punto vi direte:
e voi in che modo
avete interpretato questa cosa?
Chiaramente, la prima cosa
che viene da pensare,
e in tanti ce lo dicono, ci dicono -
potete immaginare, all'inizio
della nostra avventura.
Nel 2007, iniziamo a immaginare Sardex.
Io vengo da un paesino di 10.000 abitanti.
All'epoca eravamo la seconda provincia,
medio-campidano, più povera d'Italia.
Iniziamo a pensare Sardex,
e nel 2009 diventiamo la prima.
Quindi, come dire, già la situazione
inizia a migliorare.
(Risate)
A questo punto cosa succede?
Scoppia la crisi economico-finanziaria,
e sapevamo che dalla crisi economica
sarebbero derivate due cose:
carenza di liquidità e stretta creditizia.
Noi già venivamo da una situazione,
in Sardegna, di "credit crunch",
di difficoltà di accesso al credito;
quindi non avevamo un'idea
di cosa sarebbe venuto dopo.
Pertanto ci siamo posti la prima domanda,
che è molto semplice.
Mio padre, il giorno dopo
la caduta di Lehman Brothers,
ha preso, si è alzato
ed è andato al lavoro.
Per lui non era cambiato nulla:
la sua azienda era in grado di produrre,
le altre aziende
erano in grado di produrre
ed eravamo lì,
con i nostri bisogni intatti.
Quindi, nel momento in cui noi
siamo in grado di produrre,
cosa è veramente importante?
Trovare il modo di continuare
a scambiarci i beni o i servizi.
Quindi, la mancanza di moneta
non è un problema:
sarebbe come dire, direbbe qualcuno,
che non possiamo costruire una strada
perché mancano i chilometri.
Esattamente la stessa cosa.
Cosa abbiamo fatto?
Abbiamo creato un sistema
di credito reciproco,
e ci siamo ispirati principalmente
a due esperienze:
una è l'esperienza della banca Wir,
che nasce nel '34 in Svizzera
e inizia un sistema di scambio dove,
a seguito della crisi del '29,
sempre per via
della mancanza di liquidità,
le imprese contabilizzavano
ogni volta che acquistavano un debito
nei confronti delle altre imprese
che partecipavano
a questo circolo economico;
e ogni volta che vendevano,
contabilizzavano invece un credito
nei confronti di queste imprese.
Oltre a questo, ci siamo ispirati
a un altro progetto
che è, diciamo, fondamentale
nella storia dell'economia
che è la proposta di una
"International Credit Union"
di John Maynard Keynes.
Keynes, che si occupa per tutta la vita
di relegare il problema economico
a un problema di secondaria importanza,
dice: "Dobbiamo riscrivere i rapporti
tra debitori e creditori".
In che modo?
Trattando simmetricamente
debitori e creditori:
poi vedremo in che modo
questo ha influenzato il nostro progetto.
Come funziona?
Molto semplice:
un Sardex equivale ad un euro.
Prima si è parlato di "moneta virtuale":
in realtà, mi preme dirvi
che si tratta di una moneta digitale.
Virtuale deriva dal latino virtualis,
e significa "nient'altro che in potenza":
qualcosa che in potenza
deve essere reso in atto.
Da questo punto di vista,
l'unica proprietà in potenza
che il danaro ha in sé è il valore.
In che modo viene attualizzata?
Nel momento in cui cediamo il danaro
nei confronti di un bene!
Quindi il danaro è valore in potenza,
e diviene in atto non nel suo possesso,
ma nel suo cederlo ad un altro.
Comunque, un Sardex equivale ad un euro.
A questo punto io mi iscrivo alla rete:
potete immaginare costruire
una rete da zero cosa è significato:
siamo andati a raccontare il progetto
a centinaia di imprese,
e finalmente troviamo
un pazzo che ci dice:
- "Sì, ci sto! Chi siamo?" - "Tu"
(Risate)
... per il momento.
Dopodiché, da lì abbiamo cercato
di coinvolgere sempre più imprese,
e nel giro di un anno avevamo 250 imprese.
L'impresa comunque si iscrive,
e mette a disposizione dei beni o servizi,
i beni o servizi
che vengono richiesti dalla rete.
Ogni volta che vende, riceve un credito;
ogni volta che invece acquista,
contabilizza un debito;
ma ha la possibilità
di scendere sul suo conto,
e quindi di acquistare,
ancor prima di aver venduto,
attraverso un affidamento
che è la collettività a dargli,
che è l'insieme delle imprese iscritte.
Questo cambia completamente i rapporti,
e da bilaterale il rapporto fiduciario
diventa multilaterale:
ovvero, ogni credito, ogni stretta di mano
all'interno del circuito
è un atto di fiducia
tra il singolo e la comunità,
e tra la comunità e il singolo.
Siamo partiti con il Business-to-Business,
quindi con le imprese,
per poi andare avanti secondo una logica
che pian piano ha conquistato
migliaia di imprese.
Poi vedremo [che] sono 3.000
le imprese, vedremo i numeri.
Ma qual è questa logica?
La logica è che nel sistema che viviamo
ci sono due spinte contrapposte,
ovvero debitore e creditore
vivono due spinte contrapposte:
per ogni credito, c'è un debito.
Questo significa che io, creditore,
sarò spinto dal fatto
che ho un premio di tesaurizzazione,
ho dell'interesse
ad accumulare sempre più credito.
Questo impedisce al debitore
di ripagare il suo debito.
Quello che abbiamo fatto
è trattare simmetricamente
debitori e creditori,
quindi eliminare l'interesse,
eliminare il tratto
di liquidità della moneta
per far sì che il creditore
fosse portato a spendere
al più presto il suo credito
e mettesse in condizione
il debitore, in questo modo,
di ripagare il proprio debito,
in una spinta che porta all'equilibrio.
L'unica posizione sensata,
nel circuito Sardex,
è stare attorno allo zero:
se io accumulo un miliardo
di fantastimilioni di Sardex,
sono un deficiente, tutto qui.
(Risate)
Ce li ho perché li devo spendere,
e per nient'altro.
Abbiamo poi deciso
di far entrare nel circuito
i dipendenti delle imprese,
perché erano venuti a mancare
quelle che sono, secondo me,
delle cose fondamentali.
Da un lato, tutti i bonus e i premi
per il lavoro straordinario:
non c'erano più soldi,
non si potevano più dare.
Li abbiamo ripristinati in crediti.
Questo significa maggiore
potere d'acquisto per le famiglie,
significa spingere sulla domanda aggregata
di beni o servizi locali
e fare in modo che nascano
delle relazioni forti
tra dipendenti e imprenditori.
Quindi, dopo aver lavorato
sulle relazioni tra imprenditori,
abbiamo lavorato nelle relazioni
tra imprenditori e i propri lavoratori.
Ma non solo: i lavoratori
hanno un'opportunità straordinaria,
quella di chiedere anticipazioni
sulle retribuzioni future.
E abbiamo visto veramente dipendenti
chiedere anticipazioni per qualsiasi cosa:
da una ristrutturazione
della casa a un matrimonio,
fino alle spese dentistiche.
Perché oggi come oggi,
in una famiglia monoreddito,
anche affrontare le spese
dentistiche diventa difficile.
L'ultimo passaggio
sarà l'ingresso dei cittadini.
In che modo faremo entrare i cittadini?
I cittadini che sceglieranno
di premiare le imprese del circuito
riceveranno dei bonus
in crediti spendibili,
in crediti Sardex spendibili
all'interno della rete.
Questi sono i risultati
che abbiamo ottenuto:
come potete vedere, 170.000 operazioni.
Dietro ogni operazione,
una stretta di mano
basata sulla fiducia tra due imprenditori.
Si esce dall'anonimato:
quando uno paga in Sardex è diverso,
perché se vado a pagare in euro,
nessuno mi chiede: "Tu cosa fai?"
"E a te che cavolo te ne frega?"
Se tu vai e paghi in Sardex,
la domanda è spontanea:
- "E tu di cosa ti occupi?"
- "Ah, io faccio questo".
Perché si rientra in una dimensione umana.
90 milioni di euro di transazioni
negli ultimi tre anni,
di cui 42 solo quest'anno.
Velocità di circolazione: cos'è?
È la velocità attraverso cui i crediti
passano di mano in mano.
Una moneta fatta per essere spesa
circola velocissima,
non se la tiene nessuno: 12,35.
L'euro, 1,5.
1120 percento è la crescita
delle transazioni nel sistema.
In questi anni, quando abbiamo iniziato,
non avremmo mai immaginato
di vedere quello che è successo.
Di collaborare con Yale, di collaborare
con la London School of Economics,
che stanno studiando il nostro modello.
Di essere invitati,
come succederà il sette di dicembre,
dalle Nazioni Unite,
a parlare della diffusione del modello
nei paesi emergenti.
Ma ciò che ci aspettavamo, e così è stato,
è di vedere che all'interno delle persone
il bisogno di collaborazione era forte.
Qua potete vedere il network,
l'analisi del nostro network
in cui, come vi dicevo,
ognuno dei link tra questi nodi
è una stretta di mano
tra imprese del circuito.
Pertanto, quello che noi vogliamo fare
è accompagnare il sistema economico,
associando alla moneta
che usiamo tutti i giorni
un altro strumento con altre funzioni.
Accompagnarlo dal secolo dell'io
al secolo del noi,
passare dal "do ut des"
al "do ut possis dare".
Quindi fare in modo che io ti do
affinché tu possa dare ad altri.
Perché se, in futuro,
"communities will be the new currencies",
quindi le comunità
saranno la nuova moneta,
la fiducia reciproca,
e la collaborazione, saranno le basi
per costruire un modello di sviluppo
sostenibile e duraturo.
E io vi ringrazio.
(Applausi)